- [Instructor] When we're dealing
with population growth rates
an interesting question is,
how long would it take
for a given rate for the
population to double?
So we're gonna think about doubling time.
Now if you were to actually
calculate it precisely
mathematically precisely,
it gets a little bit mathy.
You need to use a little bit of logarithms
and you'll probably need a calculator,
but I did that here in this spreadsheet
by calculating the exact doubling time.
So this is saying that if
a population is growing
at 1% a year,
it's going to take almost 70 years
for that population to double.
But if that population
is growing at 5% per year
then it's going to take
a little over 14 years
for that population to double.
If the population is growing at 10%,
we know mathematically it's
going to take a little bit
over seven years for that
population to double.
Now, I was able to calculate
this as I just mentioned
using a little bit of fancy math,
but what we see in this next column
is there's actually a pretty
easy way to approximate doubling time.
And this is known as the rule of 70.
And the rule of 70 is used
in a lot of different areas,
a lot of different subjects,
people in finance would
use it because once again,
you're thinking about things growing
at a certain percent every year,
but you can also use it
for things like population growth rates.
So what we see with the rule of 70,
and let me just write that down,
rule of 70 is that you can
approximate the doubling time
by taking the number 70
and dividing it by the, not
actually the percentage,
but just the number of the percentage.
So for example,
this right over here is 70
divided by this one here,
which is equal to 70.
And notice this 70 is
pretty close to 69.7.
If you wanted to figure out
or you wanted to approximate
the doubling time,
if the population is growing at 7% a year,
well what you would say is, all right,
what is 70 divided by seven?
Well, that is equal to 10.
So this would be your approximation.
And if you were to do it in
a mathematically precise way,
it would be 10.2.
So if you're taking,
say an AP environmental science course
and they're asking you for the,
how long it takes for something to double
let's say a population
that's growing 7% a year,
they're probably expecting
you to use the rule of 70.
So let's say that we have a population
that is growing at 14% per year,
and that would actually be
a very huge growth rate.
What I want you to do is pause this video
and approximate how long would it take
for that population to double?
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So as I mentioned, we're approximating,
we don't have to do calculate
the exact doubling time.
So if we're approximating,
it's going to be 70 divided
by the rate of growth.
So in this situation, this is
going to be 70 divided by 14,
which is equal to five.
So if a population is growing at 14%,
it'll take it roughly
five years to double.